من القاهره ينضم الينا كل من الدعيه احمد
المالكي ومفسر الاحلام دكتور عبد الله
كمال اهلا بكم دكتور احمد يسعد صباحك
اعتبرتهم تفسير الاحلام الذي يؤمن به
كثيرون بانه كقراءه الابراج حدثنا اكثر
لماذا يعني همم هذه الرؤيه لك
صباح الخير عليكم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
همم قناه العربيه همم في الحقيقه خلينا بس
نقول احنا انطلقنا من الكلام اللي احنا
قلناه ده همم اولا همم يعني كثير من الناس
للاسف الشديد او قافوا حياتهم على مساله
تفسير الرؤى والاحلام وما الى ذلك يعني
فهمم تجد احيانا همم المراه او الرجل همم
ترى المراه يعني مناما او يرى الرجل مناما
ثم بعد ذلك همم يوقف حياته على تفسير
الرؤى نحن همم في الحقيقه لا يمكن همم
الرؤيه من كونها موجوده همم لان القران
ذكرها همم القران قال في سوره الانفال
الامريكهم الله في منامك قليله وقال
ابراهيم عليه السلام همم يا بني اني ارى
في المنام اني اذبحه سيدنا يوسف كان يعدد
نعم الله تبارك وتعالى عليه فقال ربي قد
اتيتني من الملك وعلمتني من تاويل
الاحاديث وكان الملك يقول افتوني في رؤيا
ويقول قضي الامر الذي فيه تستفتان سيدنا
يوسف
فالقضيه قضيه من الذي يعبر اولا انا قلت
لا يوجد تفسير كتاب او كتاب في تفسير
الاحلام لابن سيرين حقيقه هو لا يوجد اصلا
لابن سيرين رحمه الله كتاب في تفسير
الاحلام مع العلم ان ابن سيرين عليه رحمه
الله كان من المفسرين الكبار في زمانه وهو
من التابعين ابن سيرين عليه رحمه الله لم
يؤلف لانه قال لو الفت كتابا لا الفت في
رثاء رسائلك
الاحلام ام انه ما فيش دلائل علميه على
ذلك مع انه في وقائع دينيه وعلميه للموضوع
حتى نفهم انا ارفض تفسير الاحلام اللي
موجود الان بيظهر على الشاشات همم من همم
بعض الاشخاص همم خلينا نقول اللي لا تنطبق
عليهم الشروط لا تنطبق عليهم الشروط لانها
علماء نعلمونا الذي هذا العلم هذا علم هذا
كفتوه كما يقول شهاب الدين انفراوي عليه
رحمه الله بيقوله هو ده الفتوى بدليل
القران قال قضي الامر الذي فيه تستفتيان
بل قال همم العلامه شاهين عليه رحمه الله
قال ومن اقدم على تفسير الرؤيا دون علم
ولا درايه فانه اثم ياثم هو عامل زي
الفتوى بالضبط اولا ان يكون مثلا
في سياق الكلام ولكن في كمان نعطي الدور
لدكتور عبد الله في هذا النقاش دكتور عبد
الله يعني كلام شيخ احمد وغيره كثير
يقولون بانه تفسير الاحلام
وهو مثل الابراج بالجرايد انت بتقول ايه
والله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
علم تفسير الاحلام او تعبير الرؤى او
تاويل الرؤى والاحلام فهو علم ثابت له
اصوله قواعده علمه من علمه وجاء له من
جهله يعني نلتقي مع الدكتور او مع فضيله
الشيخ الداعيه احمد المالكي في الادله
التي ذكرها من القران الكريم وهو بذلك
يعني يعتبر وضع الامور في نصابها الصحيح
من ان هذا الامر فتوى بالفعل
وكلامه الذي ذكره قبل ذلك كان في مداخله
اخرى في سائله تسال
ووجدت تفسيرا مخالفا لرؤيتها
للحقيقه والواقع وما ينبغي ان يكون عليه
العلم في التاويل والتفسير لان هذه الحاله
كانت يعني حاله مصابه ببعض يعني الاذى
وتحتاج الى علاج معين يعني هناك منتشر
بالفعل وناس غير متخصصين في تفسير الاحلام
وتعبيرها وتاويرها وهؤلاء يمثلون يعني
يعني ضامه او بلاءا المفترض ان من يرى
رؤيه او من يرى حلما في المنام ان يتوجه
به الى عالم بهذه الامور دكتور عبد الله
او بمن يحب
اما بالنسبه لابن سيرين اما بالنسبه لابن
سيرين فهو تابعي جليل ولد في عصر سيدنا
عمر بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه وارضاه وتوفي
سنه 110 من الهجره 110 من الهجره يعني في
بدايه توفي في بدايه القرن الثاني الهجري
الشيخ احمد يقول ليس هناك تفسيرات ليس
هناك مؤلفات خاصه بتفسير الاحلام انتم
مفسر احلام على اي اساس او ما الاساس الذي
تستندون عليه لتفسير احلام للناس
الشيخ احمد يتحدث عن عدم وجود تفسير لابن
سيرين لابن سيرين مجمع ومدون في كتاب ابن
سيرين ابن سيرين لم يؤلف الكتاب ال- ال-
ال- المعروف حاليا والمشهور حاليا ولكن من
جمع تفسير ابن سيرين هو الواعظ النيسابوري
وهو الذي جمع هذه التفسيرات عن ابن سيرين
يعني نجد ان المترجمين من الذهبي وابن
كثير وكل من ترجمه لابن سيرين قالوا بانه
عالم وله باع كبير في تفسير الاحلام
والرؤى حتى ان الامام الذهبي
وفسرها الامام ابن سيرين ووقعت بالفعل كما
قال قال
لما وسع هذا الكتاب ولم تبدا هذا الكتاب
الذي يؤلفه في التراجيد اذا
سيرين له تفسيرات هذه التفسير هذه
التفسيرات اذا علمنا ان عصر التدوين فيه
بدا في القرن الثاني الهجري الذي توفي في
بدايته ابن سيرين فان العلماء اهتموا
بتجميع تفسيرات ابن سيرين حتى تم في
الكتاب الذي يعني هو مشهور بين ايدينا في
هذه الحيه
ابن سيرين لضيق الوقت ايضا انا احدثك
بالعلم اليوم يا شيخنا اليوم الانسان
عباره عن طاقه العباره عن ذبذبات يعني كل
ما يفكر فيه ما يحصل معه في حياته ما
يتوجه من قد يفكر به في احلامه اليس هذا
صحيح
نعم نعم هذا نعم هذا صحيح يعني اجيب على
حضرتك
بكلام النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كما عند
مسلم النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام قال
الرؤيه الصالحه من الله فاذا راى احدكم
ماء ما يحب قال فليحدث فلا يحدث بها الا
من يحبك واذا راى احدكم ما يكره خلاص في
فزع في خوف فما الى ذلك لم يجد عالما
حقيقيا معبرا همم له درايه واخذ هذا العلم
عن علماء معتبرين فقال النبي عليه الصلاه
والسلام فليتفل عن يساره ولا تعوذ بالله
من الشيطان وشرها ولا يحدث بها احدا فانها
لن تضر وعند مسلم ايضا همم النبي همم في
الحديث الرؤيه الصالحه بشرى من الله وفي
رؤيه ثانيه اللي هي تحزين من الشيطان
بتلاقي الشيطان يبقى الانسان يصاب بعض
الهم ببعض الحزن وما الى ذلك في حاجه
ثالثه اللي هو حديث النفس يعني انسان ربما
يبقى عنده حديث نفس في اليقظه في
ذلك همم في المنام فقالوا في النهايه في
نهايه الحديث فاذا راى احدكم ما يكره فلا
يحدد بها احد وليتفل عن يساره ولتحوذ
بالله من الشيطان الرجيم شكرا جزيلا دعايه
احمد الملك هي مفسر الاحلام دكتور عبد
الله كمال شكرا جزيلا لكما